humans have created a very simple but
powerful tool for dealing with pathogens
one that we didn't even realize was so
powerful until a few centuries ago
soap
so has been around for many many
Millennia made from various oils and
Alkali the goal was cleanliness whether
of objects or of a person's own body but
it wasn't until the mid-1800s that a few
doctors began to realize that washing
their hands kept their patients safer
and healthier but even as we began to
understand more about microbes and
people continue to push for soap as a
way to contend with pathogens it wasn't
until the 1980s that anyone established
some sort of national hand washing
guideline for hospitals